e é possível bater uma casa com carrinho
controle remoto vamos agora pessoal em 3
2 1 olá pessoal bem-vindos a mais um
aqui pessoal a solução de um problema é
que é o problema que eu estou a ter
muito aqui nesta casa que é lixo no chão
ela aliás o principal problema não é
lixo no chão é ter um último em casa que
traz lixo para o chão enfim no vídeo de
hoje eu vou tentar construir uma
organismo usando um carrinho controle
remoto para me ajudar a bater no chão
com toda a diversão possível que eu
posso ter ninguém se eu passar muitas
horas a bater no chão com uma vassoura
ou até mesmo comprar um aspirador que eu
não sei se vai funcionar mas vamos de
estar aqui pessoal é por isso que eu
estou aqui a fazer esse vídeo para
testar com vocês também se resultou não
é mais pessoal deixa eu posso moleque
aqui neste vídeo
a todos os nossos amigos não sei se
conseguem ver aqui mas temos 4.99
milhões de subscritores falta muito
pouco para os cinco milhões então se
puderem ajudar apertar o canal como
todos os vossos amigos pessoal lhe
ajudar mesmo muito muito aqui o canal
atingir essa meta é esse carrinho aqui
que é um ford eu tenho aqui a casa dele
e o cabelo é muito bonito olha isso ok
então fica mais ou menos assim dá para
andar em estrada ok e é muito bom fazer
dribles é mesmo muito bom já vou mostrar
ali fora e eu nem te contei mas o outro
carro foi para arranjar porque os looks
do eu o motor do carro do carro mais
potente então ainda vai ser uma defesa
grande só daqui a mais ou menos um mês
talvez é que eu consigo voltar a pegar e
andar com ela então até lá tudo aquilo
que vocês queiram ver de controle remoto
vai ser com esse carro ok a minha ideia
era juntar essa peça que
há mais ou menos quando nós
perguntássemos o carro para a frente e
ele tecnicamente a investir no chão é o
que é que vocês acham acham que vai
resultar agora vocês podem ter outro
problema que é a vossa mãe não quis
deixar de lutar carrinho controle remoto
em casa e assim um problema a partir daí
ó não há nada a fazer as mais é que
manda um
e aí
e para chegar aqui ó
e eu fiz olha é por isso tens que não
esquece o
e aí
e como podem ver o pessoal do carro é
bem potente deu para ver aqui uns drift
se bem que este piso não é o melhor
porque já tinha água então carro
deslizou muito eu tive que alguns
acidentes são e como podem ver um arco
bem o chão tem aqui algumas marcas de
pneu mas que vai facilmente é só passar
aqui a água e sai né aliás eu até vou
testar agora que é para ver se sai como
podem ver se saiu ali um pouco ok é só
passar a vassoura e já saiu impecável
agora eu esqueci muito pequeno pormenor
é que este carrinho não é à prova d'água
o outro que foi para arranjar esse é à
prova d'água e este aqui eu não tenho
certeza por isso tem que limpar muito
bem o mecanismo ali dentro um água em
contacto com bateria não pode ser outra
compacto muito rápido não ele vai
estragar vamos lá para cima para o
estúdio para fazer isso ok pessoal vamos
limpar o carro
[Música]
e agora só não sei se as baterias quanto
pagou todas vão estragar mas espero que
não eu acho que não que eu disse tem
tudo cobertura de borracha ok pessoal tá
tudo limpinho vamos lá então começar a
nossa intenção eu acho que a melhor
forma de colocar mas a vassoura aqui na
parte da frente do carro ou é com cola
quente a colar meses tu a capinha do
carmo aqui de frente mas com essa parte
não é muito resistente é só um plástico
eu acho que o mesmo prender aqui assim
aqui por baixo esta borracha eu acho que
é melhor forma e para isso a cola quente
não serve então pessoal eu acho que vou
tentar passar aqui essas coisas essas
anilhas eu não sei bem como é que se
chama mas isso certo ok então como é que
nós vamos fazer isto parece ter mais
comprido eu vou juntar aqui dois exato
só pegar estas advindas em casa se
juntarem duas ela fica melhor ok é
porque ganhou comprimento da outra e
certo da mesma forma pessoal nosso
protótipo está bom
e agora só tem que ter a certeza que
essa parte da vassoura toca mesmo no
chão porque eu estou reparar que ela
fica mais ou menos levantada eu não sei
se dá para perceber daí fica mais ou
menos assim tipo curva
e apesar de este carrinho ser tração
traseira e a parte da frente está presa
na vassoura portanto o carro que acaba
por não andar tanto que a pastora também
não vai conseguir pegar hoje porque tá
um pouco inclinada então vou ter que
melhorar aqui todos tema é
e aí
[Música]
o ok pessoal eu tentei aqui uma
geringonça eu não sei se vai funcionar
acabei para utilizar a qual que entre as
rodas da frente ficaram ligeiramente
levantadas mas eu acho que vai funcionar
porque o carro com e tração traseira eu
acho que ela acaba por funcionar pela
primeira vez vamos ver se a tração
traseira está a funcionar isso pelo
menos não consegue arrancar né
a aventura está a funcionar muito bem
até
o que está no perfil dela não é ela
médico já pode contratar aí para a tua
missão espacial alguém pode ser um
primeiro eu te levaria para marcos que
que eu achei ele aqui dentro tem cereais
que uso que atirou ao chão ok especiais
eram para ir para o lixo era um para ir
de fora mesmo tempo já ninguém ia comer
que eles caíram no chão estão cheios de
pelo cheio de porcaria ali dentro
portanto que os homens vir com aqueles
comentários de rodar que estás a
desperdiçar comida se o operário pra
frente ficar comigo assim ó
e aí
o teste número um ok eu tenho que pisar
nesse primeiro tempo só nós passamos o
texto aqui ó ai meu deus aconteceu um
pequeno acidente eu acabei por me aturar
demasiado o carro entrou se o estudo
para aqui agora vou ter que vai ser ao
contrário agora vamos empurrar todo mês
com isso daqui para frente 321
e é isso
e funciona funciona o lixo todo ali está
completamente limpo o churrasco dele
como podem ver tal lista toda ali depois
é só colocar o lixo na pa e tal feito
está perfeito o ideal até era ter outro
carrinho com uma pá na frente e chocar
com os carrinhos um no outro assim
tiramos a vassoura ea pa olha isso vai
ficar com uma ideia ó ela não acho que
tens que me contratar atravessar outros
são melhores no primeiro teste nós
passarmos um segundo teste nós passamos
vamos fazer então o terceiro teste vamos
tentar investir migalhas de bolacha ou
de cereais o que for vamos tentar com
coisas maiores talvez tipo o papel e
bocados de alumínio tipo lixo maior ok
eu vou tentar com isso então eu vou
colocar desde cereais todos aqui no chão
ok vamos voltar a espalhar isto vou
colocar aqui neste domingo também já não
tem muito papel eu vou deixar tipo aqui
assim ok e vou deixar também aqui um
plastico de umas bolachas que já foram
comidas eu vou deixar aqui mais à frente
e para me deixar aqui e
se espalhar mais cereais agora sim é o
verdadeiro teste só o que é que vocês
acham acham que esse carro vai passar
acham que não vai passar comenta aí
deixa muito like e corre lá ver se isto
acontecer meu posse funcionar outro tipo
mega assim que isso é uma louca é
possível bater uma casa com carrinho
controle remoto vamos tenho agora
pessoal em 3 2 1
um certo sucesso ok eu falar um
pouquinho papel porque tava fora da foto
dele ok agora já está na rota do papel
vamos ver se tu consegue vir aqui este
rasto agora tens um banco
bom senso lixo tá tudo aqui é bom
pessoal eu tô super orgulhoso eu tô
super orgulhoso porque eu construí aqui
uma maquininha que vai dar para eu ver a
casa vão divertir também e vocês podem
construir isso em casa se construírem
algo assim parecido manda um adm lá no
meu instagram ok ou faz um histórico o
meu arroba eu vou partilhar já tem
algumas pessoas que fizeram a
customização em casa também na
playstation 4 ok eu tenho recebido as dm
meu vocês estão incríveis tentei fazer o
carrinho também e é isso pessoal se
quiserem que eu continuo a construir
este tipo de coisas malucas coisas que
eu me lembro de fazer comédia é embaixo
deixa muito like partirem com um amigo e
é isso pessoal fiquem bem e até a
próxima como é que é pessoal agora
também estou aqui na tela final a falar
com vocês a verdade eu não fui embora
ainda aqui embaixo vocês tem dois vídeos
que eu já fiz lá atrás que podem ver
podem assistir e vão se divertir
certamente portanto tem esse vídeo aqui
tem esse vídeo aqui entrem lá
divirtam-se e agora sim é que eu vou
embora tchau tchau